America is defined by one single word: possibilities.
Possibilities.
I want to thank the team at NASA for once again showing that, that's who we are.
And now let's take a look at the very first image from this miraculous telescope.
Mr. President, if you held a grain of sand on the tip of your finger at arm's length,...
...that is the part of the universe that you're seeing.
Just one little speck of the universe.
And what you're seeing there are galaxies.
You're seeing galaxies that are shining around other galaxies...
...whose light has been bent,...
...and you're seeing just a small little portion of the universe.
Mr. President, 100 years ago, we thought there was only one galaxy.
Now, the number is unlimited.
And in our galaxy, we have billions of stars or suns,...
...and there are billions of galaxies with billions of stars and suns...
...and we're getting our first glimpse.
As you said, Mr. President, we're looking back more than 13 billion years.
Light travels at 186,000 miles per second...
...and that light that you are seeing on one of those little specks...
...has been traveling for over 13 billion years.
And by the way, we're going back further because this is just the first image.
They're going back about 13.5 billion years...
...and since we know the universe is 13.8 billion years old,...
...we're going back almost to the beginning.